yesterday I told you with all the normal
disclaimers and caveats that a new CNN
poll has Donald Trump down by a historic
14 points to Joe Biden in national
presidential election polling 55 to 41
now this is important not just because
the 14 point lead is unconscionable but
it's also important because a challenger
hitting 50% so regularly five months
before the election is not very common
Donald Trump has had an absolutely wild
tantrum in response and I want to give
you a look at what he said and then we
can fact check it so Trump has been
reportedly going nuts on his campaign
manager Brad Parr scale
how could I be losing to Biden how could
these polls be true we talked yesterday
about this zoom call during which Corey
Lewandowski asked what exactly is our
message for re-election in November and
this all led to Donald Trump having a
tantrum tweeting quote CNN polls are as
fake as their reporting same numbers and
worse against crooked Hillary Dems would
destroy America so there are two
empirical claims being made there the
first is CNN's polling is bad Trump
calls it fake the second is that his
numbers were even worse against Hillary
in 2016 than they are today against
Biden and yet he still managed to win in
2016 so this is a great opportunity to
just examine empirical claims first is
CNN a good pollster or a bad pollster
remember the polling arms of a lot of
these media outlets are separate from
the reporting or broadcast arm so for
example Fox News polling is actually
quite good despite Fox News Channel
being a right-wing hack job CNN polls
are also well ranked they're ranked B+
by 538 so CNN polling is quite good
Trump's claim that cNN polling is bad is
incorrect second claim from Trump is
that he was polling even worse against
Hillary in 2016 and he's still won
that's simply not true if we go back and
look at June
of 2016 meaning five months before the
2016 election just as right now were
five months out you can see if you're
watching that the with the exception of
one or two outliers Hillary Clinton was
more or less polling four points ahead
of Trump and reminder she did win the
popular vote against Trump by a couple
of points if you look at the polling of
Trump versus Hillary right before the
election you can see it was even closer
Hillary was ahead by three point two on
Election Day and she won by two point
one because remember these are popular
vote polls so Trump is wrong on both
counts
he's losing to Biden now by more than he
was losing to Hillary and CNN is a
pretty good pollster but it doesn't
really matter because this is all
narrative it's what can you tell your
supporters that will get them fired up
and fake News CNN is lying to you gets
his supporters fired up last thing Trump
then tweeted that he has hired a
pollster to debunk the CNN poll because
he was clearly so triggered by it
tweeting I have retained highly
respected pollster mcLaughlin and
associates to analyze today's CNN poll
and others which I felt were fake based
on the incredible enthusiasm we are
receiving read analysis for yourself
this is the same thing they and others
did when we defeat defeated crooked
Hillary in 2016 they are called
suppression polls and are out to dampen
enthusiasm despite three and a half
years of phony witch hunts we are
winning and we will close it out on
November 3rd again the letter Trump
posted with this analysis is all wrong
the McLaughlin memo wrongly states that
the CNN poll finding Biden up 14 is from
an all adults sample that's not true CNN
says very clearly in the methodology it
is a registered voter
sample so even the analysis of the poll
that Trump paid for is bogus so the
final message this election is nowhere
near over this is going to be a fight
every voter should assumed from can win
their state and you should operate on
that basis this is a big gap so
certainly Trump will number one need a
credible story as to here's how I am
fixing the economy here is how I am
dealing with the coronavirus well
because otherwise he's not going to be
able to turn it around so expect that
story to be told it'll probably be a
story of rehabilitation of the American
economy and number two Biden probably
needs to mess up at this point um in
order to squander the lead but both of
those things can happen we can't be
complacent we all have a role to play
let me know what you think I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman privacy calm is one
of our sponsors and they're giving you
$5.00 just for using their free service
at privacy comm slash Pakman privacy's
of service I've been using for a while
now I love it it saves me a bunch of
headaches it's completely free and it's
very quick to set up and here's how it
works
when you pay for something online or
over the phone instead of exposing your
real credit card number privacy lets you
generate virtual card numbers the
payments are withdrawn from your
checking account but your real card
number stays completely private and you
do it all with one click you can
autofill the card number in your web
browser on the phone you can create 12
virtual cards a month you can set
spending limits freeze them delete them
whenever you want I especially love it
for free trials where you need to give a
credit card number because I can destroy
the virtual card number as soon as I
give it to the company and I know I
won't be charged in the future if you're
ordering food over the phone why do I
need to give a restaurant my real card
number I don't have to companies don't
have to know who you are your real
credit card number is protected from the
data breaches that happen unfortunately
more often than we would like and it's
completely free they do have a paid
version with different tiers where you
can create more virtual credit card
numbers per month cash back rewards
extra security features but go ahead and
sign up for the free service it's a no
brainer companies can't charge you
unexpectedly you're protected from
identity theft that costs you nothing
and privacy is giving you $5.00 to spend
just for signing up when you go to
c-calm / Pakman